hi theo my name's john i'm from upstate
new york i'm 17 years old i'm a senior
in high school and i'm going off to uh
well i'm going off to the world after
this and i
thank you for calling john i appreciate
your brother and i appreciate you uh
and uh upstate new york
and they cut somebody's head off one
time up there on a greyhound bus man i'm
sorry for reminding everybody about that
and i didn't plan on reminding you but
i just said it and then i realized you
know that i'd said it
um
i can't believe you're 17 jeepers man
you're in high school you've got to
graduate from what sounding like an
adult
technical
institution bro i can't
do you sound like
bro hold on a second let's go back and
hear you dog and i love you brother i do
want to tell you that homework see you
my name's john i'm from upstate new york
i'm 17 years old hi theo my name is john
i think my name is john i'm revolts
dude you sound 52 years old brother
uh and you're going out to see the world
what are you in a charles dickens novel
let's hear more old i'm a senior high
school and i'm going off to uh
well i'm going off to the world after
this and i the world are you lenny from
of mice and men is this brendan
is this brennan shaw who owes me that
thousand onward i
i'm just not quite sure what i want to
do with my life
you know i i work hard i don't get the
best grades in school but i worked hard
and
i just want to hear your thoughts on
this what do you think a young man
should do thank you very much gang
brother
gang brother and i'm sorry i was making
funny man but also i was just having a
good time
what would i do if i was 17 right now
with a deep voice
i'd probably do some [ __ ] honestly if
i'm real honest with you man i'd do
mating i'd mate with women with that
voice man you could
you could probably make love to half
your mother's friends but um
what would i do if i were 17
you know if you weren't really sure what
you would wanted to do i i don't think
joining the military would be a bad idea
because you're going to get a lot of
direction you're going to get
physically in shape you're going to get
camaraderie
and i don't think we're going to hand to
hand combat anymore
we've kind of evolved out of a lot of
that
you know a lot of war now is more press
of a button
more pomp and circumstance
you know
more kind of like the introductions but
not the actual start of the round
um
so i and here's the thing you'd be done
by 21 and you're the rest of your life
you would you would be so regimented i
think and have such a good structure
that from then on you would be able to
achieve anything you wanted
if i could go back in time i'd have more
structure
that's what i would have
um
so
what else
i don't know man maybe race carrying
you know start with like a real beater
or something start with maybe a toyota
tercel
or something yeah
or something like that
get out there dodge neon soup that bad
job
don't much neon
um
i'm upstairs
uh
yeah i would do something like that
maybe i don't know man
what is it you know i would learn
digital some type of a digital skill
or i'd learn how to teach people to hunt
with birds you know i would just find
something that you kind of like and if
you don't know what you like then try
things until you find something you do
you know one time i remember i went up
to the
counter at this
recreational facility
and there was a cute girl working there
and i was trying to holler at her and
this is
about nine years ago and
and i was kind of bored in my life i was
just bored
and she said well if you're bored you're
boring that's what she said
and i'm not saying that you're bored
brother
i'm not saying that your brother i'm not
saying you're bored john from new york
that's 50 or 40.
um
but there's a lot of things out there
man
and we just got to go do them and try
them out
so i'd say just make a little list of
things
that you love or things even that you're
afraid of
and like brooks was said like brooks
said man get busy living
you know i don't know if he said it or
not he died he died at the grocery store
and he killed himself
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one
you